♪ [music] ♪
So let's say based on the first half of
this session, you have the pricing
for your company, different multiples for
your company, and a distribution of each
of those multiples across the sector for
your company. Let's talk about the
next step. How do you decide whether your
company is cheap or expensive?
So let's turn to the third step in
deconstructing multiples.
Earlier when we talked about discounted
cash flow valuation,
we said the value of a company is a
function of its cash flows, growth,
and risk. A lot of people prefer not to do
discounted cash flow valuation because
they don't like to make assumptions about
cash flow, growth, and risk.
So what do they do instead?
They use a multiple. They do pricing.
And in doing so, they assume that they're
running away. They're escaping that
responsibility of actually estimating what
cash flows, growth, and risk have to be.
Well, unfortunately,
that doesn't work because embedded
in every multiple are all of the
assumptions you make in discounted cash
flow valuation. In fact,
when you decide to use a multiple,
whether it be PE ratios or EV to EBITDA or
EV to sales, I'm going to argue there are
two questions you need to answer before
you use that multiple sensibly.
The first is you need to identify the
variables, the fundamentals that drive
that multiple. And I'm going to show you a
very simple process for backing
out those variables.
And once you back them out,
here's what you're going to discover.
Embedded in every multiple are assumptions
about cash flows, growth, and risks,
the same assumptions you were making
in discounted cash flow valuation. Second,
as those variables change,
you need to tell me how your multiple will
change. So let me give you an example.
One of the variables that drives PE ratios
is expected growth. As growth increases,
PE should increase, but you need to be
much more explicit than that.
You need to be able to tell me for every
1% increase in growth rate in your sector,
how much will the PE for a company go up?
And the reason is without being able
to answer the second question,
you cannot compare PE ratios
across companies within a sector.
So let's try the trick that's going
to allow us to back out the variables that
drive a multiple. I'm going to take
an example. Let's assume that the multiple
I'm looking at is the PE ratio,
and I want to find out what drives the PE
ratio. Here's what I'm going to do.
Because the multiple is an equity
multiple, I'm going to go back to the
simplest equity valuation model I can
think of, a stable growth dividend
discount model. Value of equity per share
in that model will be the expected
dividends per share next period divided by
the difference between the cost of equity
and the growth rate.
It's called the Gordon Growth Model.
Let's say I divide both sides of that
equation by the earnings per share.
On the left-hand side now,
I have the PE ratio.
On the right-hand side,
dividing dividends per share by earnings
per share gives me the payout ratio.
I end up with an equation for the PE ratio
for a company in a stable growth dividend
discount model. And guess what,
the PE ratio for a stable growth dividend
paying stock is a function
of three variables: its payout ratio,
its cost of equity, and its expected
growth rate. In fact,
I can give you the dynamics.
Holding all else constant,
as my growth rate increases,
my PE ratio will go up.
Holding all else constant,
increasing my cost of equity,
the risk of the company,
will lower my PE ratio.
And holding all else constant,
increasing my payout ratio will increase
my PE ratio. If you're puzzled by the
last variable, remember,
the only way I can increase the payout
ratio while holding the growth rate fixed
is by earning a higher return equity.
So put differently, here's what I'd expect
to see in a low PE ratio stock.
I'd expect to see a low growth rate,
perhaps high risk, or a low return equity.
Most companies that look cheap deserve to
be cheap. So in pricing,
you're trying to make sure that when you
see a stock have a low PE ratio or a low
EV to EBITDA, there isn't a good
fundamental reason that explains it away.
You can extend this approach to almost
every multiple, and here's what you
should do. If you have an equity multiple,
price earnings, price-to-book,
any equity multiple,
go back to dividend discount model.
Do the algebra. At the end of the algebra,
you should have the variables that drive
that multiple. With PE as you saw,
those variables are cost of equity,
growth, and payout. When you do the
analysis for price-to-book,
you're going to see a new variable pop up,
its return equity. The price-to-book ratio
for a company is a function of its cost of
equity, its growth rate, its payout ratio,
and its return equity.
So with every equity multiple,
you're going to be able to identify the
variables that drive that multiple.
If you have an enterprise value multiple,
EV to EBITDA, EV to sales,
go back to the simplest enterprise value
model that you can think of. To me,
that's a stable growth free cash flow to
the firm model. Value of a firm is the
expected free cash flow to the firm next
year divided by the cost to capital
minus the growth rate. Do the algebra,
and you'll have the variables that drive
each of these multiples.
Every multiple has driver variables,
and to use that multiple well,
you need to know what those driver
variables are. So now we're ready.
We've defined, we've described,
we've analyzed. Let's talk about applying
a multiple. To apply a multiple,
there are two decisions you have to make.
The first is, what are those
comparable firms? What are you going to
define as your comparable firms?
Now, if you ask most analysts that
question, the answer is if it's a
software company, I need to look at other
software companies. If it's a utility,
I need to look at other utilities.
My pushback is, why?
If you're looking at valuation,
there's nothing in valuation that says
that a utility has to be compared to
another utility, a software company has
to be compared to another software
company. In fact, in valuation,
a comparable company is one with similar
cash flows, similar growth,
and similar risk no matter what sector
you're in. So perhaps,
we should start defining comparable much
more broadly. And second,
no matter how careful you are,
after you've got those comparable firms,
your company would still have differences
from those comparable firms.
You got to figure out how to control for
those differences. So you ask me,
is Disney cheap or expensive relative to
the entertainment sector?
I'm going to do a lot of hand-waving,
but the bottom line is I can't tell you.
Why? Because its PE ratio's close to that
of the sector, its growth rate is lower,
but it's probably a less risky firm than
the typical entertainment company.
So you can see very quickly why
storytelling can lead you into the wrong
places with pricing. So you think,
"What do I do?" To illustrate one
possible solution, let me look at European
banks in November of 2013,
and Deutsche relative to those European
banks. I know this is an extended table
with lots of companies on it,
but here's what I'd like you to focus on.
Focus on Deutsche's price-to-book ratio
which is 0.67, and focus on the median
for the sector which is 0.89.
Based on the price-to-book ratio,
it looks like Deutsche is cheap, right?
But at the same time,
Deutsche's return on equity of 0.93% is
much lower than the typical return
on equity in the sector.
Deutsche looks cheap,
but there's a good reason why it looks
cheap. So here's one way to explain
the difference. I took the price-to-book
ratios for the European banks and I ran a
regression against two numbers.
One was the return equity,
the second was the tier 1 capital ratio.
Why do I include these two variables?
The return equity tells me how good the
projects are that the banks have taken.
The higher the return equity,
the higher the price-to-book ratio.
And the tier 1 capital ratio tells me how
under or over-capitalized these banks are.
I would expect banks that are in a high
return equity and have a higher tier 1
capital ratio to trade at a higher
price-to-book ratio,
and the regression backs it up.
The T statistics is significant,
the r-squared is 24%.
I'd like it to be higher but it's as good
as it's going to get.
I plug the numbers for Deutsche
into that regression: its return
in equity which is minus 0.93%
and its tier 1 capital ratio which is
15.13%. I come up with a predicted
price-to-book ratio for Deutsche of 1.00.
At its actual price-to-book ratio, 0.67,
Deutsche looks cheap even after I've
controlled for its low return equity and
its tier 1 capital ratio.
I'm not suggesting that statistics is
going to give you the answer every time
you got to do a pricing,
but it's a tool that should be in your
toolkit to control for differences
across companies. So you want to try
pricing your company?
Here's what I suggest you do.
Find your comparable companies and define
comparable broadly. It's good to have a
bigger sample rather than a
smaller sample. Then once you got that
bigger sample of comparable companies,
pick a multiple, pick the variables that
you think should drive that multiple,
and try some statistics. You'll be
surprised at how much power you'll
get once you can start to put a number on
the questions that you have to answer.
You're well on your way
to pricing your company.
♪ [music] ♪